par terre par mère et par les airs les
civils tendent toujours de fuir le
Soudan comme ils peuvent car la fenêtre
se referme une trêve de trois jours
expire dimanche mais le Cécile feux n'a
pas été respecté ce qui complique les
évacuations des ressorties sans
étrangers hier des tirs depuis le sol
ont endommagé un avion turc et blessé un
membre d'équipage l'armée soudanaise
accuse les paramilitaires de violer la
trêve aucune partie n'a toutefois
revendiqué ses tirs le Canada pour sa
part poursuit son opération d'évacuation
aujourd'hui de vols des forces armées se
sont mises en route vers la capitale
soudanais d'hier
375 Canadiens ont déjà été évacués
environ 300 autres sont en attente je
peux confirmer qu'au moins un vol
d'évacuation canadien est prévu pour
aujourd'hui
200 membres des Forces armées
canadiennes reste déployés dans la
région pour cette
ligne d'effort
dans la capitale soudanaise le ravage
des bombes se voit dans la rue les
carcasses de voitures incendiées
côtoient les immeubles détruits et
noircis par la fumée la pénurie
d'aliments se pointe déjà dans les
commerces ce qui laisse présager une
nouvelle famille ou soudain selon le
programme alimentaire mondial de l'ONU
un tiers de la population avait déjà
besoin d'aide alimentaire ici Carla
Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal